hey happy Wednesday everybody out there
me and Tom and Conan looking over our
shoulders watching everybody yeah all
right this is just gonna yeah it's
choppy this really wide choppy when we
first start just two streams because it
hates us
yeah is there anybody on there yet
there's 40 people I want people just
showing up for I think what it starts
loaded in the pro the software for the
chat that seems to be when it does all
the lagging yeah I think it's the chat
service that's on the side of the does
it yeah so it's all you guys has thought
yeah just catch it just kidding we love
having you guys here that's like the fun
part well it's supposed to I think it's
kind of like an add-on service to the
streaming thing you know yeah and I
think it just takes time for everything
to catch up because I noticed that once
everybody's in in the chat they posted
that the lag goes away yeah
it's making all those connections I
guess I mean somebody maybe in the chat
room might be able to explain it but the
first couple minutes it's just choppy
yeah well like I said I don't think
there's anything particularly no you
know everybody knows what we look like
yeah just imagine that we're smooth
imagine that we're better looking than
we actually are
well I ain't better yeah I think that I
would probably tell everybody that just
imagine I should you know what that's
really funny we should we should print
out pictures or in pictures of like
really really attractive people and just
like hold to say this right now yeah we
could just move around yeah we can even
like Oh cut their mouths out if you want
okay local moms in mark mango badger
death Owens is in side quest hero
Deborah therapies especially Rob's
Deborah Hackett don't we all
Sammy's here anonymous automations want
me to imitate my
dad that's weird how how these little
[ __ ] things that I do become
characters on the show I never get tired
of you doing that turkey next thing just
because I still remember him coming back
and that was like two years ago right
when you came to like two and a half
years ago when I still laughs I can't do
my dad until like a certain topic you
know I mean comes into play
yeah and then all of a sudden I start
channeling my dad's reactions to this I
know how he would react to it and I know
the [ __ ] that he would say you know that
helps you can't just you have to have
context the champ they said they would
yes - okay yeah I get it you can't just
like bust and it's just not as good you
know if you bust it out all the time
then yeah the only reason why people ask
me to do is cuz it's funny when I do it
and it's funny when I'm doing it because
Dennis decides to speak he is Dane - yes
until they kind of like channeling the
force or channeling the [ __ ] spirit
or something or you know something will
happen and I'll hear in my head my dad's
reaction to it how he would react to it
it's five only met your dad one time and
it was like a long time ago when he came
here for Thanksgiving yeah how many
years ago was that a couple years that
was a while back it was like maybe no it
was longer than that because it was
two-and-a-half years that you went when
he had the bypass okay yeah so I think
it was a couple years before that so it
might have been four years a long time
ago so I don't even remember so I only
met him one time because he doesn't live
here yeah so that was always he came
here for like a week or something and I
don't even remember I remember him
sounding like that it's just I can't
really remember a lot of what he said
when he was away he stays at home you
know he's he's retired now you know he
sees pretty weeks he just stays at home
and reacts to television he still
watches television yeah he tells me what
he saw on television and he'll tell me
the same old stories have been telling
me for like 20 years that's kind of like
yeah a lot of like really old people do
that they forgot they told you or they
just like only have like so many so I
have so many stories and if I if I give
you
anything new he's like nah like I was
telling him about Christ MIT Christ myth
theory you know like from oh jeez you
got into that got into Christ myth can a
lot of times yeah with uh you know
doctor doctor price well the yeah I
believe the the the I believe it's the
fact that there was no historical Jesus
that it's a it's a mythological
construction based upon yeah religious
literature okay and it's it's a
combination of a lot of things that were
around for thousands of years going over
back to ancient Egyptian stuff well I
was pointing out certain things that
didn't make sense and these old
scriptures and he was like he said ah
[Laughter]
there was a historical Jesus this is a
myth logical person using uh yeah now
they're not that was real dude you know
just they don't you know it's too late
in the program to change it yeah cuz you
know they've lives too long give me like
not everybody because you know I've
known some older people that were you
know just as spry er just as like
mentally well when I first heard the
Christ myth theory I was uh open-minded
to but resistant I was going like now
can't be no no no no that that religion
was based on an actual historical person
that lived you know cuz I thought there
was other references to him they are but
it's after yeah they're much later yeah
and they were added later by the church
they weren't there in the oldest
versions of those histories so it was
added later the church played in there
yeah I mean you know like seventh
century most of right this is you're
talking about way late you're talking
about like many many centuries they're
all kind of shenanigans could have gone
yes and maybe not even shenanigans in
the sense that like somebody was doing
like nefarious [ __ ] on purpose it was
just kind of like they believed it yeah
it's just like [ __ ] happens and it gets
just gets cobbled together like over I
believe that Christianity was first
century that it started like in 30 ad
and there was a Jesus and all this [ __ ]
happened and they wrote about him and
their stories know
Jannetty actually the Christianity we
kind of know and these are our third
century long time after it happened yeah
there there are slight traces of it in
the late first century and some in the
second century but most of the [ __ ] that
we know of became from the early third
century so you're talking two hundred
something years close to three hundred
years moved two hundred sixty years now
after the so called a fact or the
supposed fact but the no it couldn't
have happened yeah
the history is all wrong whoever wrote
those stories didn't know much about
what had happened in 30 ad and didn't
know much about Pontius Pilate they
didn't know much about the geography you
couldn't walk from one place to another
in a night like it says yeah they're the
dish that was wrote by people that
didn't know that area very well right
and it was I believe written by Jewish
Romans in the Jewish Diaspora that moved
into Rome and they were leaving Jewish
type religions and entering into more
Roman type religions and Jesus is a
perfect mixture of Jewish and Roman and
that's that's what they're talking about
yeah it's just a mixture of a lot of
those characters and it's got a lot of
Greek in it too and as Oracle Munn
pointed out in the comments it got
mushed together with the mithran cult
exactly exactly
it's it would be kind of like imagine
you believe in Islam and then you and
your family moved to the United States
and you're here for a lot your family is
here for like a hundred years or 70
years
you're now born in America your only
Muslim because your grandfather was
Muslim but you don't really feel like
you're Muslim so you say you know what
Islam is not the Islam that's in this
book that we believe Islam you in other
words they start making up a more
Americanized version of his law yeah
they're just like stuff that's more in
line with more with the culture Ang's
that they live and they want to keep
exactly the things that the ancient Jews
believed in the first century we're in
line with Jewish culture I received with
Roman culture the Romans and the Jews
were at a war with each other
a long time you know and there was a
that is basically Canaanites you know
Judea area and they they they believed
in a pantheon of religions their
pantheon of gods and a lot of them were
literally called zealots and they fought
kinda like Isis kind of like redneck
versions of the Greek religion in a way
yeah there was come a Greek yeah yeah
the Canaanite the Canaanite Pantheon was
kind of like a redneck version of the
Greek pantheon there wasn't a big
difference between them but they were
country people and they didn't get a
long row where they didn't want to be a
part of the Roman Empire Rome occupied I
mean there's a big war that went on but
over time over generations you know they
were moving into the room and putting it
into the Italian peninsula in the heart
of the Empire and they've been there
generations they didn't feel like
foreigners they just felt like Romans so
they just romanized Jewish regions
that's what all they did so it's
Christianity yeah it's just it's jus
like I said you can see it all over the
world and like every relief system and
it's just that's what people do it's
like they move in any places and it's
like it's syncretism as yeah syncretism
it's a jewish sect it's been romanized
the lots to fit better in and they did
that with a lot of [ __ ] they did that
with an Isis cult and other Egyptian
cults did that exact same thing
Mithra ism was was a Roman version of a
Persian religion about Mithras so there
was always a Roman version of all the
foreign religions yeah and Christianity
was one of them yeah I'm sorry it's just
I spaced out for a second because I was
thinking about Eddie Izzard about the
Romans taking all the Greek gods and
yeah and one of the weird things about
Christianity is that it was it had
elements stolen from it from an Attis
cult I think it was Addis I think it was
Addis and in Christianity you have your
Savior he's crucified on a religion on a
[ __ ] on a cross and his blood washes
away your sins it's a big sacrifice that
came from Jewish basically blood ritual
magic with with scapegoating when you
have a lamb and you let the goat go
but then your good lamb you sacrifice
that and that washes the blood washes
away the sins of the tribe that's
exactly what happens in the creek it's
like a symbolic the exact same ed yeah
well there was a Roman cult it kind of
has something like that it was a cult
Attis and the the most devout
worshippers of the cultu ad has cut
their own [ __ ] junk off
they became total eunuchs that's
hardcore and evidently in the time of
the you know like in the first century a
lot of Romans kind of would refer to
early Christianity and the cult of Addis
as both being insane super superstitions
so who knows the the very early early
Christians might have believed in some
crazy [ __ ] whatever they believe it is
long gone it's all been erased yeah we
only have we only have modern versions
of Christian well yeah because a lot of
it was destroyed who's destroyed when
they sure and if you know they're like
okay well this is the version that's
work it is going forward and they're
just like let's just we're not gonna
like and you know that's why that's why
the New Testament has all this
references to you know our Father and
our supper as opposed to there was
another supper and our Savior was born
of a woman he was born of a woman he was
a [ __ ] barn you're like yeah he was
born what they're talking about is that
there were other versions of
Christianity that must have been when he
was never born he was just a celestial
figure and way sitting at the right hand
of God on a throne
probably an archangel above Gabriel and
you can bypass Judaic law if you appeal
directly to God's highest son it gets in
other words you could cheat yeah you
could cheat Jewish lays a loophole if
you saw if you just kind of accepted the
blood sacrifice of this higher angel
that's what they're talking about
yeah finding a loophole because yeah the
Old Testament law was brutal you
couldn't actually it says in certain
parts of the Old Testament you know
[ __ ] Yahweh says I give to you these
[ __ ] crazy laws because
they're impossible to follow you'll
suffer because that's what we like we
yeah watching other people ever cuz well
I need it well Yahweh was was a Demiurge
yes what that's where the grapes I'll
call him Demiurge is basically a devil
God he was God and devil yeah together
and you know the Covenant was about you
will do this or else and then there's
all these Sukkot and then do the right
or wrong it was just a ritual
purification
don't touch that [ __ ] Ark do you keep
it if this following you try to catch it
I will [ __ ] you yeah that's basically
what what Old Testament stuff was about
you know your firstborn is mine yeah
they were killing the firstborn
yeah which they people in admit that
from Bible stories in Bible class fun
Bible story I mean you know no the
original the original Yahweh you killed
your first boar both livestock and
humans they even got the damn clay pots
with the dead babies to prove it and
those are in the areas where they do
that stuff yeah so humans sack and child
sacrifice yes and then it says don't
give any your children to Molech which
that was the Yahweh's other brother yeah
don't give it to all that in debate give
him give it to Yahweh okay it's funny
because when I was a kid cuz I wasn't
raised super religious or anything um
but I had an extended relative that was
kind of more religious than we were and
gave me like a kids you know like a
really pretty like illustrated book of
Bible stories and even some of the ones
I mean they left out like the really
horrific ones but even the ones that
were in there I mean the Abraham and
Isaac story was in there and I remember
reading that as a kid and being like
yeah it's [ __ ] up yeah well they're
making a comment about reforming Judaism
don't sacrifice any children not that
off even if God is telling you but ya
know it says even if God tells you to do
it don't do it
that's over that's what it means yeah
says you prove it yourself and that's
what they're trying to do what they try
to do with that story is to get people
stop killing their children even
if they thought God was tell him to do
right okay because they were trying to
break them or that tradition you know I
mean the the head of the household would
be like yeah I know they don't want us
to do this but I prayed and God said we
have to kill this child yeah well they
just in the new stories it says even if
God tells you to do it don't do it yeah
because it's like oh yeah yeah
Oracle Munn says points to self
preacher's kid now atheists because I
actually read the Bible and dad couldn't
explain it all to my satisfaction that's
kind of where I came from as well like I
said I wasn't raised real religious but
I think other than reading the Bible
stories and thinking man that's really
[ __ ] up and that doesn't seem right to
me but also I got really interested in
other mythologies Greek women you know
Greek Roman Egyptian mythology when I
was a kid and I thought to myself you
know like people believed this once just
as stringently like as people believe
like Christianity or Islam or whatever
now it is the same so I so I thought
well there must not be any difference
between those two things dude I think I
figured that out when I was like 9 or 10
years old and you know it's I don't
really go around saying you know oh all
the you know that what the Bible says is
bad the Bible says a lot of things it's
a mixture of looking fine pretty much
anything whatever I want there it's a
cultural library yeah of people that
believed in things going back a long
time that Old Testament is not as all as
people think it is though probably like
3rd century BC Septuagint there was
there's a Greek version of it the
version the Hebrew version of it was
actually a copy of the Greek version the
oldest is the Greek is the Greek version
of the Septuagint and it's the Torah
came from that and the Greeks got it
from Canaanites you know they were
translating it from Canaanites and
evidently the original doesn't exist but
it's not that old and the stories that
are in it are not that old so they're
reboots yeah it's like a older story
have much oh like I said and another
thing to that kind of you know sort of
cemented it for me it was when I got
into in school like into humanities and
stuff
and you were reading stuff you know that
was older like Babylonian stuff you know
that that was that parallel like the
Noah's Ark story anyway yeah Yoga mess
it was like way way older right is the
greatest hits to the Canaanites yeah
that's all it is all the stories that
like people liked and they survived and
they were yeah write them down and the
Jews believed that they were basically I
they kind of believed in a pseudo
history in a way could because we only
have we only have the Old Testament in
the Septuagint to to give us these
stories but they were already edited you
know a lot of style the stuff yes was
cut out this is all of the Canaanite
gods all their stories and then all
stuff that was even old or some of it's
like you said Babylonian all reheated
and condensed saying that the Jews that
lived in the third century at least were
kind of like the end result of of a war
between a bunch of gods and that their
tribe was chosen over the other ones
that they killed all the other ones off
yes you know it says in in Genesis it's
got God telling the Jews to go out and
wipe out entire cities and you know
don't even let the [ __ ] children of
the animals survive you know that didn't
happen there's no evidence of that
probably what most likely happened is
that over time Judaism kind of condensed
into a couple of major one religion with
a couple major divisions in it you know
kind of like you know Protestants and
Catholics you know denominations I guess
you could say yeah and it wasn't really
done by conquest it was just done by
cultural evolution over time they all
started to kind of like believe the same
thing in the way that Greeks over time
all started to become Christian yeah you
know after the edit they were Christian
towards the end of the Roman Empire it
was the same process with the Jews yes
and and I believe also Islam is also
kind of [ __ ] religions don't come
into power through combat or
the sword they they usually just do it
through politics and evolution over
looks like cultural memes it seems like
the stuff that sticks with people like
the stories that people argue late if
populations start expanding through
reproduction more than anything else but
then they write down their histories
that well we run the show because we're
badasses and God was on our side we
killed everybody else that was a boast
very heavy bull yeah in those days well
everybody not how it happened everybody
wants to be the one that's like the
favorite and you know we're the ones
that have all the magic powers on the
other side and so we'll gonna like we're
gonna spite all our enemies there is no
evidence that that Muhammad went out and
conquered a bunch of land with a bunch
of new Muslims that the evidence
actually points to the fact that they're
in in the Middle East and it was it was
all Christian kingdoms they were
fighting one another and one Christian
Kingdom took over a bunch of land and
then over time they rebooted
Christianity into Islam and there's a
very good chance that there's a very
good chance that Muhammad is not
historical he's a person he's a figure
like Jesus or Moses
yeah he's either either completely
fictional or something that's like just
cobbled together yeah remember other
people there's a lot of parallels
between Muhammad and King Arthur there's
a lot of parallels and there are some
people that are you know have kind of
dug up some certain things you know the
historicity of the Quran is difficult to
verify they won't show you the oldest
copies of it the history of surrounding
people's during that time don't mention
anything about Quran Zoar new religions
coming or Muhammad I think it was a but
Christian kingdom conquered a lot of
part of the Middle East and then in a
short period of time it rebooted the
religion into a Middle Eastern version
of Christianity they put a character in
charge of it like Moses and like Jesus
in a way but elements of King Arthur
like a warrior king yes you know well
that's a very compelling narrative I did
a lot of humans like really it's a
natural thing that they do yeah because
when I was a little kid I remember
hearing you know being taught things
about king or
they're like in third and fourth grade
and we were told you know and this is in
in America yeah you know and like a half
Hispanic school in Dominguez California
at that time and we believed King Arthur
to be a real person that's how they told
us I remember learning about King Arthur
in school but I can't remember if they
taught it as like these are a bunch of
neat stories like a legend or if they
actually said oh it was based on a real
guy I don't really remember
i I I'm leaning toward i think more
fiction I think they really remember a
legends I remember having the impression
that it was a real person hmm and they
might have been different school just
the district yeah he was and then and
then later on like in sixth and seventh
grade you started studying English
literature and then there was references
to King Arthur and and and that you know
that England was basically created by
King Arthur in a way yeah but that it
was a legend but that he was a real
person yeah okay which I'm not saying
and that's the kind of thing too about
the the whole Jesus myth thing is that
I'm not saying that there wasn't a guy
that with that name that did a couple
things that he like was at a certain
place at a certain time or whatever but
I just think the one that people
perceive as that figure never existed
and the same with King Arthur I'm not
saying that it wasn't based on a real
dude I'm sorry
we're guitar start talking about damn
mythology now King Arthur the name comes
from Arcturus it's a Roman yeah
it means bear okay but there's kind of a
problematic with that some of the
earliest English literature back in real
Old English was Beowulf and that was a
about a geek king in England okay
Beowulf translates to means big wolf but
they're talking about bear yeah so I
think there's a possibility that Arthur
is a 1400s or even no Renaissance reboot
of Beowulf it's more courtly more friend
that yeah that actually because I think
that the warrior king that's archetypal
when you see that across a lot of
different cultures that is so that must
be like a human yeah so I think these
young and archaea archetype if you want
to put it that way
I think these guys in Britain need these
British guys in Brittany you know
whether whether it invaded France sat
around they knew about Beowulf big wolf
so they made a more stylish version
Arcturus Arthur yeah Arthur big wolf
wolf and then it's a lot more
complicated story of you know then
there's Christianity in a proto
Christianity Germanic Christianity with
the Holy Grail and everything and it's
these courtly stories about morality is
there's a lot of just Chaucer right who
is it the wrote that [ __ ] which one
l'amour to Arthur who wrote that [ __ ]
not Chaucer no it wasn't Chaucer as a oh
damn now I can't remember now we
remember not sure if there's Mallory
okay yeah I think if you when you look
at those stories they serve as a
religion almost like a national religion
or cultural religion teaching a lot of
the same values that religions would
teach yeah and like I said that seems to
be like a pretty common yeah human thing
that's why we have like archetypes and
Wyatt why certain stories like certain
themes of stories like reappear across
cultures no matter how widely separated
they are and Islam is kind of doing that
same thing it's the same kind of yeah
some kind of situation you know yeah
people are saying yeah I did okay Thomas
Malory that's what I did get it right
that's like well I'm surprised I pulled
that out of my butt but yeah one thing I
wanted to do kind of a shout out just a
real quick mention is that you know how
like a lot of times we're on Adam Saenz
conspiratorial show we've been on there
several times sometimes I'm on there by
myself sometimes me and Tom are on there
together like talking about various
topics they do adam sane and company do
a conference every year of you know
paranormal stuff mysteries all that kind
of stuff normally they have it in
Nashville where they're from but of
course this year you know they can't do
that
so they're gonna do an online conference
over the weekend of September 25th 26th
and 27th I believe and I'm going to be
giving a presentation at it I don't know
what my time slot is yet and I'm not
entirely sure like I have an idea of
what I want to do a presentation on
it'll probably be I might do something
like a kind of a true-crime paranormal
crossover type of thing where it's like
a true-crime thing with you know a
paranormal aspect to it or a weird
aspect to it but um I'll decide I have a
couple ideas I'm floating around but I
just wanted to put that out there I
think he's got a commercial for it and I
might put that in some of our shows
so yeah that's end of September that's
gonna be and it's gonna be a completely
online conference there's tons of other
speakers and it seems like it's gonna be
a good time and I'm gonna give a talk at
it so we'll see how that goes
also allows me how I know all this stuff
I had a classical education I came up in
a military academy as a kid and then
went to a really expensive private
school in Brazil for a while and then
[ __ ] army and then lots of reading
when I got out of high school I didn't
even I had an I had an IB an
International Baccalaureate I didn't
need to go to [ __ ] college I went to
college for about a semester it was
[ __ ] boring I quit it's just politics
and I saw how that [ __ ] was gonna go
you're just gonna get in a bunch of debt
and I was I was going for accounting
until I [ __ ] bought up gateway 2000
[ __ ] PC and started [ __ ] around
with that and I realized that Excel was
doing a job that was learning to do yeah
it was like stuff like that you can I
was like do I want to be a CPA and just
sit around [ __ ] I would have been a
miserable accountant so you have to be a
certain kind of person to want to do
yeah and then you know as the 90s went
on I realized that the entire job market
was just being flooded with people with
degrees just useful idiots you know and
I just had a bad feeling about education
it turned out to be right the future was
going to be an online jobs and creating
things and technology would change over
time
if I'd had today's technology now
computer technology back in 98 I'd be a
billionaire by now but we just didn't
have it back then I could foresee it
yeah yeah I mean but people the internet
wasn't developed enough you know now we
got robots working for us
yeah that's why you people are
unemployed we've replaced y'all with
robots robots make the shirts now this
kid I'm gonna make these shirts it's
gonna be like kind of hard to see
because these are the these are what's
going on the screen so they're like not
is it anything this white over there
right there
you can arms reach you you are the kids
all right this one here is gonna well
that's three different things yeah this
is gonna be two shirts that's gonna be
the 13 o'clock is gonna go on them yeah
that's a back label yeah check that out
weyland-yutani and then wave in
corporations there's gonna this will
probably be light blue or white on a
black shirt yeah cuz we got blue in we
go put that over all right then this one
I thought this was gonna have a circle
around it yes not no Plissken yeah man
we got a new a new main logo I love this
one yeah like how I came out actually
I'm gonna make a move I even bought some
extra blank shirt so I could have some
of them too so we've got about thanks I
got ready today I have a red one a blue
and a white so we made I got five new
screens I got a bunch of screen material
I need to get the little gaskets to seal
the screen and then they're come in a
couple days I'll be here in a couple of
days and then I got the envelopes to
send em out yeah so then I'll make a
bunch of screens for that and we'll
start production and I'll cook that [ __ ]
in there it's gonna look
badass he's cooking the [ __ ] well cook
it up much like the [ __ ] you're cooking
right now yeah he's making fish curry
right now it's in there slow cooking
speaking of the UK I wanted to mention
because I made the card earlier we
discovered cuz last night I was just
like man I was too exhausted I worked
late last night and I was still ugh to
Plissken one [ __ ] right that was my
concept yeah it's it's it's the [ __ ]
Ford Cobra logo but it just says bliss
Plissken on it
yeah but yeah so I didn't really feel
like watching a movie or anything like
that because I'm like my brains too
mushy to pay attention to a movie which
is why we're not reviewing a movie today
however we did discover that to be not
only has a bunch of the old US Kitchen
Nightmares on there they also have a
[ __ ] ton of the UK Kitchen Nightmares
yes which everybody knows are way better
I like the u.s. ones too but the u.s.
ones just like everything compared to
you know British TV and US TV like u.s.
TV shows are just like edited so
drastically yeah I just can't it's like
really hard for me to watch American TV
shows are edited to the lowest common
denominator they [ __ ] dumb them
things down to like a person with like a
70 IQ and a really short attention span
yeah it's like a bunch of really quick
cuts and a bunch of [ __ ] over-the-top
[ __ ] the continuity really isn't is
isn't there sometimes less they're
shorter because we shouldn't have more
commercials than they have in the UK and
then after this after the [ __ ]
commercial they'll recap so try to pad
everything out yeah it looks like they
look a lot better than British stuff cuz
they're more expensive but they don't
watch as well they're not as
entertaining I think they're not no I
mean some of the UK Kitchen Nightmares
some of them we've watched like probably
Ted like some of the really good ones
and it cuz like the one that I made the
card out of this one cracks me up a lot
because this was I don't I don't know if
this play this pubs even still there
it's called the fish and Anchor it was
in Wales and Lampeter and
[ __ ] couple that owned it was Mike and
I can't remember the wife's name Aaron
is Gerren yeah and these two it's just
every time I watch it it cracks me up
because it reminds me because I you know
I lived over there for a while and so it
reminds me of like all the accents like
the way that they talk and the two of
them are just like at each other's
throats just constantly they're just
like screaming and shouting at each
other and just cat and that's like it
cook for a while the first time that we
saw in that episode like a few years ago
like he just started like every time he
was out in the kitchen and like needed
me for something he'd go cold okay
[Laughter]
season three though I think it's like
season 3 episode summer letters that
there's an episode on there called The
Priory we watch that one again that
motherfucker's hilarious this defunct
Cathedral was turned into a [ __ ]
restaurant yeah I think the restaurant
was a carvery
yes we would call that a buffet here in
the United States yeah a bunch of damn
meat on it roasts and [ __ ]
mashed potatoes and starch you know I'm
too stodgy [ __ ] and it made its living
by packing a couple hundred [ __ ] old
people into it every day with their
[ __ ] 50% off coupons by what meal get
we get two yeah selling $9.99 so
everyone ate for five bucks yeah her
five pounds yeah yeah five pounds that's
prob about seven dollars right and then
uh it's just fine man he's [ __ ] old
British people in there oh they this
woman she just tweeted [ __ ] you know
she's gone like oh it's good to have a
little joint there's nothing like you
can at home you just can't always have a
chunk that's a strong Asti you guys she
was very posh yeah and I'm like going
hold on yeah do you are eating for five
pounds each your posh is a [ __ ]
but you can't afford a joint at home and
I'm thinking to myself the way she's
saying joint - it's not a sexual [ __ ]
like she's getting ready to jump on it's
a big old joint
hey old lady she's gonna get her shrink
to get her jelly meat
well what's CI okay there's many times
as I've seen that prior episode it's
like so five pounds could you eat as
much as you want like was it an
all-you-can-eat it look like I so you
could actually like I'd put those
[ __ ] out of business they've learned
well there's old farts we have a threat
we had a really good buffet before the
pandemic hit [ __ ] called koi wan it
was Chinese and Japanese it had sushi
and everything yeah okay dad every you
could pay extra for [ __ ] crab legs
and all-you-can-eat [ __ ] king crab
legs there's a huge plate hell yeah
[ __ ] boiled shrimp a chip when they
saw me show up Menem Chinese people
[ __ ] it all here he's coming he's
coming man
cuz I'll sit up there just eating on the
shrimp yeah we see it all their shrimp
belly like a five muscle five pounds of
flexing shrimp just like it boy sure I
think we've been Shin that before like a
royalty boiled shrimp you can like you
it seems like you can just eat them and
eat them and eat them in their fall yeah
that's kind of here the whole from the
top from the front from the you get four
from the cocktail sauce not [ __ ] up you
got man so whole [ __ ] soup bowl
[ __ ] cocktail sauce a cocktail sauce
I said I could probably drink cocktails
easy to make easy to make I know it is
but yes horseradish and lemon yeah I
really I really like to go in there it's
like and you you know you got a good
deal for your money yeah and oh you need
that rice yeah yes sorry for the rice
and noodles but it's like if you stayed
with the meat and veggies yeah eat a lot
more I need a lot more and it's a lot
more healthy for you because you won't
get carbohydrate crash and blow up yeah
it's just just meat man go it's like key
guy I like sushi but there's too much
rice in it yeah yeah just like the lady
at the Priory it all does do you realize
that I think that season goddamn when
did that season of Kitchen Nightmares
come out in the you kids probably like
2003 or something like that so all these
people are probably dead now
well because I mean all the people that
were in
there were like 90 yeah and it reminded
me like when I was a little running an
old folks home really yeah and like it
who Gordon was saying that to which I
thought was very funny he was talking to
blue-rinse per gate he called them but
it's like it made me remember like when
I was a little kid what is this with
like really old people and like what
it's you know I guess they all love a
bargain or whatever but on fixed incomes
yeah well I am too yeah thing is is
their fixed incomes are from retirement
yeah and you know that's try not very
much but I just I just remember what I
feel making some money when I was a kid
you know my grandmother and her sister
would take me to the mall when I was
little and they in the mall we used to
have it wasn't a Morrison's what's that
other buffet chain dance is not allowed
anymore I can't remember what I was
[ __ ] it would answer like Morris and
now we didn't have any of those there
was to collect competing but when I was
a little kid too called smorgasbords and
they okay people back then ate on them
they had [ __ ] aspic and jello and [ __ ]
yeah
that's what I'm that's what I'm thinking
of this was like that look and you just
went through that I mean when I was a
kid I thought it was like super cool
because you could let go through and you
can pick whatever you wanted and then
like when you went and sat down at the
table there was like all these
refrigerator cases that had all these
like individual pieces of cake and pie
and stuff and then I get to toddle over
there and get key lime pie or something
like that and it was like a big day out
we got a dress you know we've seen the
f-word it's pretty good yeah and some of
those are on to be - I don't know
because when we were looking at UK
Kitchen Nightmares I didn't realize that
there had been a sixth season of that
and that came out in like 2006 or 2020
episodes I don't know if that's all the
episodes or was their seasons tend to be
sure and the Badger says he's given up
on UK TV sniff like sign up for Amazon
Prime
yeah and get the show yeah television is
on its way out I mean it just is from
another era like I said it's not even
people that you know watch shows that
are on TV like broadcasts we watch them
on and you wait until later to watch
them so you can binge amol at one time
the only thing that we watch on TV is
the new word of Ramsey show uncharted
and we
the art and war on later yeah it's
[ __ ] basically TV is now like
eight-track you might as well be [ __ ]
each a reel-to-reel yeah that's just
[ __ ] it that's an outdated it's
outdated dying [ __ ] um we call it
media Piccadilly that's what anyway
connealy cafeteria thank you very much
best that is that's the other one we had
Piccadilly that was in the mall and
mordant's was standalone oracles asked
me our buffet is gonna come back at the
end of the year um this is what I've it
no nothing's coming back nothing's ever
coming back the lock towers are never
gonna [ __ ] open civilisation is gonna
collapse the [ __ ] station go Lord
each other it'll be cross between
[ __ ] a tidal wave and a race war
that's the spirit and [ __ ] Mad Max
it'll all be [ __ ] want one thing
it'll be kind of like Katrina depending
on what state you live in now if you got
balls you'll just blow it your state
will just kind of blow that [ __ ] off go
yeah let's just go ahead and [ __ ]
open it back up we'll take the hit
let the old and weak die open up their
bucking buffets Tom what's this I'm just
gonna I'm just trying to be realistic
with people depends on if people want to
[ __ ] drop their nuts if you want
choppy nuts and be [ __ ] stop being a
[ __ ] then you can open it up and it'll
be all right
but the phase will serve human meat they
may the very well yeah well if they
don't do if they don't get their [ __ ]
straight soon they will serve human meat
[ __ ] soon if they don't get there
people don't realize how fragile
civilization is this [ __ ] and look like
Mogadishu and [ __ ] two months you do
the wrong thing it'd be a [ __ ] human
flesh markets and [ __ ] slave markets
and all kinds of [ __ ] selling white
girls up on [ __ ] counting up on
[ __ ] blocks of [ __ ] so when the
Soviet Union fell you know [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands of [ __ ] Russian
girls so I can just vanish they don't
know where they went
I think they were sold sold them all off
to Middle Eastern brothels and [ __ ]
harems yeah yeah so you know people have
this artificially [ __ ] inflated view
of the way the world is and what human
beings are
and when all your wealth is gone and
electricity doesn't work and and money
no longer works people rapidly go into
the gutter and if you don't you die
that's why bad [ __ ] happens in other
countries you know I grew up in a
country where bad [ __ ] happened to
Brazil and that was during the good
times of Brazil my friends that stayed
there most of the kids I grew up with in
Brazil they're here now they they left
their family did whatever they could to
get them out of there they were
upper-middle class and upper class
Brazilian people they're all over here
now and what's happening in Brazil now
it's [ __ ] horrible horrible and you
know you'll never really hear about it
but it you little eventually get out but
it's just lawless anarchy and
dysfunction it's like the Star Trek
Mirror Universe you know yeah you bring
that up a lot yeah [ __ ] because it's
happening now once that veil once that
mask of [ __ ] civility is torn away
it's bad human nature is not that good
when you when you're in a world
surrounded by poor and desperate people
all right becomes a low trust society
very quickly and it's got a certain
synergy it starts to snowball anyway
yeah [ __ ] car boss I'm gonna soil it
Ross look like thunder on the Barbarian
times that's what he said yeah yeah
exactly
I'm fine with I'm fine with with Pookie
eating me if she has to you know I
haven't got there Pookie survived is she
out on the porch where is she
her Beijing we're fighting earlier
Beijing climbs up on that because we
have we probably mentioned this before
but we have like one of those things
that you bolt into the wall and it's
like all these little things that lead
up to the what Anonymous is going yeah
we need to find our salvation with the
World Health Organization in China yeah
yeah yeah they're gonna help us yeah
yeah uh we done yeah all right I didn't
know if like the food needed we
need to check on that because I'm gay
it's not cooking it's not it's not
cooking oh I thought you were done with
it I've done with the sauce okay that's
why you want go you you hungry
yeah I just got to cook the fish in the
shrimp and then heat the sauce up and
the rice is done and then just that's it
no no no I did the prep work oh okay I
think I'm professional it would make
some meat yeah I guess we'll do that I
mean you know we've come on stream yeah
45 minutes okay yeah and I figured you
know we didn't really have make sure you
guys liked like please like the video
share and subscribe yeah we'll probably
do another livestream on Saturday
probably another movie review if I can
find something good to watch over the
next couple of days so that'll be the
next and then tomorrow witching hour
goes up and Friday a movie retrospective
goes up and then Saturday we'll see what
that is so you live again so you guys
take care out there and we'll talk to
you again very soon